eh bien oui pour la cuisine comme pour
le reste c'est noël aujourd'hui raymond
rogers cup nous ne dissimulons pas qu'il
s'agit d'une émission enregistrée marsac
le savon palestiniens nouvelle fois tout
comme si c'était vrai aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ce petit arrêt charmant et je
suis sûr que vous allez nous proposer
doit t'occupes seulement à paris à la
période de noël
car aujourd'hui bien entendu nos amis
ont fait alors la voyez vous je vais
mettre sur ce mordre
c'est l'atout m'a dit qu'il n'avait pas
de nom beaucoup de noms mais granato de
noël ce sera très bon alors là c'est du
chocolat sur les chocolats voyez-vous du
chocolat fondu ou simplement que le oui
quel jeu la mer c'est tellement fun
seulement fait pour n'importe quel
chocolat convient enfin je vous la
couverture convient mieux que les hommes
même du chocolat que l'on peut pleurer
un tout petit quand le faisant fort et
où elle est simplement sur le marron
comme ceux ci l état il va avoir son
rôle à jouer tout à l'heure il rassure
alors on l'a joué tout à l'heure alors
somme amassée de chocolat fondu tout
simplement dont on m'a aussi romancier
de vito n'importe quoi ils veulent
savoir nord du maroc chez soi et pour
cela on se croit obligé vous fait savoir
de quelle épaisseur là
oui et bien là mais nous alors
immédiatement si vous voulez faire une
meringue de l'enfer une meringue qui
sera expliquée en détail tout à l'heure
mais pour le moment nous avons dû sirop
c'est pas votre meringue habituel ce
soit il ressemble un petit peu mais
aussi ceux ci rôle à ce sirop que je
vous fais voir ici et le sirop dans
laquelle on cuit les marottes
alors il a été simplement comment
dirais-je 8000 côté de façon à pouvoir
de s'en servir leur cuir leur cuir qu on
cuit du sucre mila kunis
il ya ce souci du site ceux ci se voient
dans lequel on n'a fait que des marrons
n'est ce pas alors il ya deux jarres de
marrons nous avons fait qu il y à ce don
qui n'ont pas dit qu'ils étaient pas
entier et que devront passer
voilà on fait une espèce de piqûres et
donnera lieu tout à l'heure et puis
alors il ya les bons et les très bonnes
et pleurons garder qui seul à servion au
décor puisque vous savez que lorsqu'on
fait qu en démarrant même chez soi et
tout ce qui a beaucoup cecilia blanco
déchets alors immédiatement
nous allons pas en rigole un fou et des
plans vous allez vous en servez tout à
l'heure pour l'instant on n'en parle pas
je maintiens tout de suite alors et vous
ici jamais environ doit avoir lieu une
livre pas tout à fait le sud on est
alors dans le 4e bras environ 4 blanc
entre 80 à une petite pointe de sel dans
ces blancs et immédiatement je viens de
sirop accueillir
alors voilà parce qu'il faut qu'il ait
une autre consistance il va falloir
qu'ils soient cuits puis aux petits
boulots au bout les affaires entre le
voile été volé alors immédiatement à la
montée blanche
6 heures alors je pourrais vous parler
je pense que je couvrirai le bruit 10.2
ses marrons pour les faire fuir
on est des peluches d'abord je refuse
bien bien bien bien proprement et puis
on les mène 1-0 très léché c'est à dire
qu'on les ait bouya et puis avec la
pointe d'un couteau
on les laisse wadien comme il faut on
l'espère diam's au bistrot parce qu'ils
sont bien peu les séparent et puis si la
paire actions seront non en fait une
opération dialoguer sens lorsqu'ils sont
bien pâles et on les cuit au sucre le
sucre très léger dans un 2 0 de l'eau et
du sucre
évidemment je pourrais vous parler de
degré par degré de cuisson et de surtout
de poids de sirop qu'il s'agit là on
perd 0,6 alors c'est très compliqué en
réalité on n'est pas obligé d'être un
passeur cette professeure en distance il
faut mettre petit à petit on arrive à
faire a réalisé 2 076 or ledit réussite
avec dillon qui postule aussi vous
voulez pour employer amour de seconde
guerre attend alors et le sirop est en
berne depuis a presque trop vite je vais
donc baisser un tout petit peu le feu ça
irait pour vito et il est parce que puis
là donc c'est notre meirhaeghe habituel
voter dans laquelle on vit
ici très bon alors là j'ai même acheté
un tout petit peu le mouvement
[Musique]
sudamericana ressort mais j'ai déjà
montré je voyais aussi puisque août et
avait d'ailleurs il ya déjà une dizaine
de mois c'est au printemps
moi je monte son oeuvre est une
ressource fragile rouffach importe quel
bel et bien c'est le peu le même
principe nous nous servions à ce moment
là d'un sirop depuis est bien là l'eau
en place leur sirop de prix par ce sirop
de marans ce sirop dans lequel on puise
est marrant et celle de demain
[Musique]
alors ils ont été cuits alors je vais
reprendre ma recette qui dans ses clips
petit à petit dans du sirop et
lorsqu'ils sont cuits ans les époux ont
fait suivre le sirop douceur et en
retenant une fois deux fois trois fois
les idées les marrons temps déjà été
pris dans ce sens beaucoup plus effet
exactement les égouts dans les 103
divers hommages opération c'est ce qui
fait le monde va s'écrire ingénieurs
vous réussirez la première fois beaucoup
de marrant mais beaucoup de furets la
toile
[Musique]
si tu le sais pas
3 par le bruit web à compenser
dans l'oeuf
voulez vous je vous prie comme je vais
tout faire qui pique à ses réalités et
mappy com
[Musique]
pratiquer tous les sports
je me demande simplement si on n'y a pas
de très grands ils seront tout
simplement se brûler
ce qui part avec lui
satin bleu marron à l'oreille merci
capitaine tu peux auquel reproduites
non il reste n'a pas su mettre en mots
ceux ci risquent de faire des boules en
finlande où le blow et que ça peut être
je m'entends mieux vaut faire surtout tu
peut se faire ceci c'est que nous on
garde tout ce qui est ce qui risque
d'arriver l'espoir est bien mais ce
n'est pas très très grave mais qui
risque qu'il n'y ait pas assez tout à
l'heure de risque de ne pas y aura assez
de sucre pour la qualité de jeu blanc
alors si ce sucre se met en boule
n'est ce pas un terrien il ne fait pas
son seul office une heure il ne remplit
pas ses devoirs en quelque sorte celui
qu'ils aient en main c'est ça exactement
compliments vous allez avoir besoin de
tout ça là vous aviez et tout ça avec 4
blanc c'est très bien et pas tout à fait
car ton et je dors mieux non non non car
les 90 c'est vrai c'est vrai il faut pas
compter là parce que voyez-vous là ça
peut devenir une catastrophe
il a maintenant j'en ai mis entre 3 et 4
mais sûrement pas plus de 4 il ne faut
que si blanc à la livre de sucre 1
n'oubliez pas sa cible en a livré
certaines bon c'est bien cette meringue
pour le moment il faut pas vous avez
parlé de marange paris voilà je vais
avoir un petit inconvénient d'être non
je n'en sais pas ça j'ai peur que la
chaleur soit elle que le scanner
revendique se porte t elle ne
reconnaissait pas nous soyons obligés
d'employer une autre méthode
en fait j'espère que ça va refroidir
bon alors ici la chatterie nous avons
donc c'est marrant ces marrons qui sont
les débris les morceaux cassés que nous
n'avons pas pu n'ont pas pu obtenir rien
que les marrons entier alors ça long
passé ça c'est simplement des marrons
puis au sirop mais nous pourrions aussi
si nous voulions nous pourrions très
très très bien ne pas employer des
marrons glacés pour mettre en purée mais
simplement des marrons que l'euro nous
aurions fait cuire tout bêtement avec un
tout petit peu de d'eau et de sucre et
de vanille que nous aurions passé comme
s'il s'agissait d'une purée de marrons
et que nous aurions ajouté voilà dans
lequel je m'étais comme nous allons le
faire maintenant que du beurre et de la
crème mais surtout du beurre et de la
vanille au début cependant même avec des
maraudes
oui c'est parce que nous avons nous nous
sommes allés jusqu'au bout de
l'expérience
nous avons voulu faire des marrons
glacés pour le décor et c'est avec ce
même salon ou ici je met du beurre ni
veut en faire donc la purée de marrons
c'est ça elle en tire le plus au nord
alors je crois que vous avez très bien
compris nous avons tous nous n'avons
espèce de symphonies demande si vous
voulez l'antre la meringue est fait avec
le sirop et des marrons les marrons
eux-mêmes sont employés pour garnir les
gâteaux et nous allons ensuite
évidemment avec la mention chocolat
chocolat et beurre alors là le jeu voilà
j'ai peur qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas
plus pour excès de précautions vous
expliquerai ce qu'il faudra faire à la
mélanger valbert avons marre on ne dit
pas été préférable qu'il soit un show
non non non voyons le beurre ici et sous
les sunlights par conséquent il est en
pommade déjà tout seul ça n'avait encore
rien ne pas en être cautionnée par terre
j'ai parlé démarrant à l'honneur non non
il s'agit d'un carter iii s'agit de
faire quelque chose de froid
au contraire si vous aviez les marrons
chauds nous aurions inconvénients devoir
faire fondre le beurre une fois encore
grâce à trouver auprès difficile
employés ont dit que l'envié sans aucune
difficulté
nous faisons aucune voie y avait une
purée nous allons à détendre un peu et
de crème au sommet c'est très bien
quelle crème de la crème pâtissière
avant j'en ai cru de la pâtissière vous
aurez fait plusieurs fois nous en ferons
d'ailleurs les lundi prochain tout le
monde sait faire de la crème pâtissière
alors je vais mettre une cuillerée de
crème pâtissière pour que jma maquin
soit relativement habituel
je vais peut-être ajouter un petit peu
plus de beurre je vois c'est à voir si
nous jouons toujours tonnelle allons
voir
parfumez aussi la vôtre de crème ne
savait pas déjà partis mais tout est
très varié
cette histoire n'est ce pas tout a été
balayé ces derniers un peu dès le départ
le sucre a été bannie voilà j'ai l'air
si je dis oui j'ai pas mal mais là
encore il ya les articles deuxième
cuillère club voilà et là ce sera celui
ci est même trois jeux maintenons que
veut donc tout peu de place était de la
valise parce que quand vous n'êtes pas
assez souvent même oui la fin du second
nbc
là j'ai un petit peu de liqueur pas
n'importe quoi tout à fait mais délicat
marathon man show et nicolas bazire un
genre de morceau à la mort
la fois et bien ça y est maintenant nous
avons la crème à laquelle nous allons
four et le gâteau nous c'est péjoratif
et onctueuse fait trop chaud ça six
trophées régionaux dont nous allons
faire différemment
qu'est ce que vous vouliez faire avec la
je voulais faire des défis tzigane qui
siège au fait je vous fais voir comment
on fait ça ne fait rien toi petit
incident dû à la chaleur autrement dit
il est conseillé de se mettre dans un
endroit jeu la noire en tout cas tant
ferrer et mettons alors ici les rouge et
noir vu les génoises ou en master vous
connaissez la différence entre le mas
pelage noir ce qui les rend il est trés
tout petit un tout petit différence l'un
est composée de blancs séparez les
jaunes et l'autre de fait les oeufs
entiers alors chez eux pour un kilo
n'est ce pas de sucre
16e allons mais l'essai jeu et le suc en
même temps on les bat l'un comme l'autre
pour la main on les bat au chaud jusqu'à
ce qu'ils deviennent très très mousseux
on est encore pour la farine y ont fait
cuire dans le cas où il s'agit de de
massepain on sépare on met les jaunes le
sucre ensemble on va les blancs en neige
dans les ménages en même temps comme
l'âge à paris bon alors ici nous allons
donc voilà ouvrir ce gâteau pour le four
est bien par la wii un coupé oui et puis
aussi je veux je voudrais plus
exactement que on le voit bien
alors la taille et donc c'est un petit
peu intervenu dans mon café ça la somme
et vous peut ici comme cela vous alors
que tu ne veux pas refaire un petit peu
comme ça on pourrait parfaitement être
anti un petit pinceau aussi comme ça et
puis troyon va mettre notre crème de la
moitié de la crème n'est ce pas sur la
première épaisseur on sait faire des
couches et là on va retrouver la
meringue
on revient plus seraient minimales a pu
mettre notre deuxième épaisseur
mes soeurs quand ceux-ci toujours
remettre un tout petit peu moins fort
cette période il faut se réchauffer le
cas ici non nous n'avons pas besoin de
ça deuxième couche bush alors là bas
tout ce qui reste
si la quantité de crème vous aviez fait
était proportionnel à la taille de votre
gâteau oui oui oui j'avais s'érige non
il faut oublier que ces richesses et
s'il ya beaucoup de marrons de beurre et
ses radars alors cessé riche il ne faut
pas trop pas abuser d'autant plus dures
ont ensuite la meringue qui elle aussi
va devenir redonne une espèce de crem
qui va intéresser ce gâteau est par
conséquent essayez de manger il faut pas
combien soit quelques rangs jamais sa
première qualité
donc nous trois couches de génoise avec
la crème voilà alors nous allons passer
ce gâteau sur le plat le décor et vous
allez revenir là oui bonjour de nettoyer
monter un petit coin à bord les marques
comme ça
pas besoin d'un petit instrument là
n'ont qu'à three stories et les
décorations métro voila voila ma ce
pacte et les dettes alors le gâteau
c'est maintenant qu'intervient l'idée
d'un décor qui je te joins très sage ou
surtout un rôle avant que pour les gars
qui veulent de faire un gâteau ils
veulent que ce gâteau soit jolie s'était
alors voyez où nous allons être la
marraine comme ceux ci dessus tu vas
faire tomber comme ça tout à l'exception
[Musique]
rien laisser voilà un mois je regrette
que ce chocolat mesures n'ont ils pas
qu'on apporte peut-être à faire
on a quelques secondes soit un bon et
bien ici alors pour revenir à ce décor
auriez vous avez déjà vu faire ça quel
gâteau vous nous aviez gay mais cette
fameuse mouche d'un loup parlais tout à
l'heure
faire à peu près du même principe c'est
à dire du 1er mai qui a le goût de
fraise cela aurait d'abord goodman cela
nous sommes tout en armes à la main le
fait que la crème de marrons ne se fait
pas tout à fait quand on est aussi qu'en
cette saison n'y a pas fait ce qu'il
veut bien vous nous avez sorti des
framboises il ya quelques jours je sais
pas d'où elles sortaient et quand il y
en a à défendre dans la saison
je n'ai pas été conservé par des
procédés modernes parce que vous appelez
moderne en fait je suis aussi des fois
fois refroidie que certainement la
meilleure méthode conserver je crois que
ça y est un beau petit chapeau retournée
comme ceux ci avaient autrefois les
pâtissiers décoré sur un tour un petit
peu comme les tour de potier et c'est
toujours ça peut l'aider gnole et c'est
comme ça que un beau jour on a appelé
les pâtissiers laigneau le même pas mais
c'est vrai c'est devenu péjoratif en
rotant là si vous appelez un pâtissier
gnôle eux et ils étaient illettrés c'est
très vexé je crois que vous pourriez me
procurer un petit peu de chocolat qu'ils
auraient bien nous devrions maintenant
obtenir des cigarettes en raclant comme
ceux ci ses chocolats en leur accolant
sur le marc hé oh comme ça oui s'il
était froid il se découpera les ce n'est
pas infi lamelle
alors on va essayer un petit peu de
faire un même état et aux comme ceux ci
on obtient voilà au lieu d'obtenir
quelque chose de continuer continuer qui
roule sur eux mêmes en obtenant
simplement de la poussière le chocolat
en quelque sorte oui c'est parce que
c'est ce que nous allons faire
d'ailleurs seulement nous ne n'avons pas
obtenu le même effet qu'avec ce chocolat
qui s'est toujours bien parce qu'on fait
le très longue aussi une cigarette et je
voulais les poser tout autour de ce code
en cabine
à moins d'aller nous installer d'or je
crois qu'il serait vain non
je crois que quand on y va il va prendre
l'aventage qu'il n'était tout à l'heure
tu as l'air on va le retrouver ici va
s'étaler mais voyez vous je m'en vais
ici employé chocolat fait de toute façon
ici par exemple qui te passe au milieu
laissez aller votre imagination à
l'improvisation fait remarquer ça serait
bien on dirait du bois des copeaux parce
que tout c'est pareil nous avons
actuellement le chercheur voilà ce que
je voulais n'est ce pas obtenir et où
elle et m comme je suis le mieux oui
c'est la chaleur qui déjeunent
intervient au projet de ce morceau de
chocolat que j'ai dans les mains
dire que nous avons peut-être des amis
qui ont froissé quand même pas gentil de
parler de chaleur comme ça ça fait rire
ou ceux ci bon eh bien non je maintenant
je vais essayer compris que si ça avait
durci on aurait fait des petites la mer
dans les tournées sensible des vraies
cigarettes on arrive à faire le tri
brive 2 degrés cigarettes longue et
souple facile à manipuler et à la
citoyenneté où il suffisait de les
mettre comme ceux-ci être souple et la
wii alors nous allons masquer ce qu'on
appelle en termes de pâtisserie nous
allons marquer ici le gâteau comme cela
c'est pas quand on a quelque chose à
cacher ou masquer la pâtisserie ne l ont
pas forcément ça fait très jolie
remarqué ces blancs c'est continuer et
je vous dis regarde beaucoup que ça se
passe ici au mythique elle qui est
marrant c'est là oui on me cherchait
pour la fin c'est pour la bonne bouche
en quelque sorte bon eh bien écoutez
catherine voilà nous avons nous allons
dire que se terminer si on n'a pas le
temps de faire ça c'est très bien aussi
n'est ce pas c'est terminé alors nous
avons les marrons que nous allons
disposer ici tout autour bien rappeler
qu'à l'intérieur on va trouver
voilà un talent hors jeu car il peu déçu
on va faire comme ceci pour donner une
petite allure de rochers et voilà et
bien c'est terminé catherine je crois
que tous qu'on fait on suit pas je ne
sais pas il sourire ah ben c'est pas mal
ouais enfin voila voila j'ai le sourire
ça y est je suis navré que c'est facile
chaud bon on va faire de toute façon ça
n'aurait servi à rien de recommencer
puisque et non non ça c'est rien ne
jamais nous n'arrivons à faire coaguler
les chocolats ici est vraiment merci de
ce magnifique gâteau que nous allons
certainement avoir l'occasion d'exécuter
pendant la semaine qui nous sépare et du
jour de l'an et je crois qu'au jour de
larmes nous proposerez je vais proposer
un encadrement et adieu on m'a beaucoup
demandé d'entre eux mais pour cette
époque-ci à loger j'ai accédé à un grand
plaisir avec un bélier je fais des
crêpes sur plusieurs fonds d'écran des
claques
ah bon et bien nous font des crêpes et
ne nous croirons un peu à la charnière
bien que ce soit le jour de l'an au
revoir et bon oeil bon l'oréal versés
avant noël à tous
[Musique]